one the commission would likely  find that they were part of the problem  two  they want to stay in donald trump's good  graces  because it seems trump is going to have  power and control in the republican  party for a long period of time to come  at least through the 2022 election  if he fails to pick the winners in 2022  things may change but at least through  2022 and number three  if they can continue uh putting off  a real investigation into what happened  which would of course  uncover that the election was fine the  election wasn't rigged  joe biden just won they lose the ability  if that is made public through the  commission to keep  justifying these further restrictions on  voting  that they're passing in many states